it was Labor Day weekend and I was a
senior computer engineering student one
of my lab mates was sick and she was
sitting in the room with RJ and so she
subbed for us we went down to Primanti
Brothers and at the end of the night I
was holding her hand and we started
dating I had said to my mom that I
started dating this guy and I I guess I
must have described him in some way and
she said I know who you're talking about
how could you know who I'm talking about
said well he was the first person that
we met on campus when I dropped you off
he was wearing a yellow shirt he said
welcome to Carnegie Mellon you can put
your stuff here you can park over there
this is more would eat our and I did not
remember who she was talking about but
he said I'm sure this is who you're
talking about so then when she got the
picture she said yep that's him that was
my job I stood at the outside of Moore
would eat our I welcomed the the cars as
they came in and I was wearing a yellow
shirt so I was the first guy she met on
campus
apparently I I did ask my mom I said how
do you how could you possibly remember
that said well when you drop your kid
off at college you remember everything
so our daughter's starting freshman year
engineering she wants to do biomedical
engineering at Carnegie Mellon and she's
moving in today
two more would eat our seventh floor
which was my freshman year of dorm fifth
floor was her freshman year dorm which
she's completely mortified about